bonsoir et bienvenue dans ça vous
regarde ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir on poursuit notre
comparatif des programmes à neuf jours
du deuxième tour ce soir
l'écologie emmanuel matrouh a fustigé le
climato-scepticisme de marine le pen
hier en déplacement au havre mais au
delà des anathèmes qui propose quoi sur
le climat et à quel rythme le dernier
rapport du giec nous donne trois ans
pour agir face à face sur ce plateau ce
soir entre la ministre du logement
emmanuelle wargon et le monsieur
environnement du rassemblement national
hervé juvin dans un instant notre grand
témoin ce soir est une journaliste
engagé cela fait des années qu'elles
enquêtent et qu'elle alerte sur ce
qu'elle appelle la face cachée de marine
le pen les dessous d'un clan familial
unique où les amis proches les
conseillers de l'ombre sont issus de
l'école la plus radicale de l'extrême
droite l'essayiste caroline fourest est
avec nous ce soir enfin dans le scan ce
soir thierry bredel du cevipof passe au
crible l'importance du débat d'entre
deux tours sur le résultat final de
l'élection et puis l'oeil de blacko le
carnet de campagne quotidien signé
stéphane blakowski voilà pour le menu
c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs un face à face chaque
soir jusqu'au second tour pourrait voir
plus clair dans les programmes ce soir
l'écologie le thème est revenu en force
à la faveur du déplacement des manuels
macro hier au havre le président
candidat devrait aussi d'ailleurs faire
des annonces sur l'environnement demain
à marseille pour convaincre les
électeurs mélenchonistes bonsoir
emmanuelle wargon soit on les merci
d'être là ministre délégué au logement
ancien secrétaire d'état à l'écologie
vous vous débattez ce soir avec hervé
juvin bonsoir député européen
rassemblement national souvent présenté
comme le ministre de l'environnement de
marine le pen en cas d'élections le 24
avril prochain et puis bon soir emmanuel
emmanuel ducrocq chroniqueuse dans cette
émission vous m'accompagner pour
questionner nos deux invités sur des
sujets que vous connaissez parfaitement
et que vous suivez pour l'opinion alors
on va commencer par le programme de
marine le pen un mot pour le résumer le
localisme l'écologie nationale ou la
préférence pour les produits français
pour répondre entre autres à l'urgence
climatique on voit cela dans le détail
avec alix clio vous débattez juste après
même en matière d'écologie la clé de
voûte de marine le pen reste la
préférence nationale
sa vision pour demain une écologie
française est un maître mot le localisme
terol écologie certes c'est consommer au
plus près et retraités sur place c'est à
dire exactement l'un vertes du modèle
économique qu'on nous a vendu qui est un
modèle fondé sur le libre échange qui
consiste à aller acheter des productions
à dix mille kilomètres pour les
consommer chez nous mais sur l'accord de
paris elle se veut rassurante pas
question de le quitter je suis en effet
favorable aux orientations de cet accord
puisque je souhaite abandonner le plus
possible les énergies fossiles au profit
du nucléaire civil
dans son programme marine le pen propose
aussi de décarbonés la production de
l'énergie en investissant dans
l'hydroélectricité la géothermie et
l'hydrogène et en misant sur la
construction de 20 nouvelles centrales
nucléaires elle compte soutenir le
transport ferroviaire sans pour autant
réduire l'utilisation des voitures et de
l'avion et promet la réhabilitation des
anciens logements sans préciser le
budget qu'elle souhaite y consacrer
quelques idées pour l'écologie donc mais
aussi des propositions jugées
rétrogrades la plus clivante sa volonté
de faire une croix sur les éoliennes
objectif qu'il n'y en ait plus aucune et
d'avoir la première chose que je vais
faire c'est arrêter les chantiers qui
sont actuellement en cours et notamment
des éoliennes off shore st brieuc et
d'autres puisque l'intégralité si ces
projets vont à bout au bout
l'intégralité de nos façades maritimes
sera polluée visuellement autre
proposition défavorable à la transition
écologique baisser la tva sur les
carburants le gaz et l'électricité ce
qui encouragerait leur consommation et
son refus d'interdire les pesticides
marine le pen passe également sous
silence beaucoup d'enjeu clés comme la
gestion des déchets des sols ou la
baisse des émissions de l'industrie
autant d'arguments pour son adversaire
très sincèrement qui est écologiste et
peut voter pour madame le pen il fonde
le présenter parce que c'est le seul
projet qui assume de casser tous les
cadres et de ne pas respecter la part
écologiques et des engagements de la
france les spécialistes de la transition
énergétique les shifter insiste le
programme de marine le pen serait très
éloignés voire contraire aux objectifs
climatiques de la france
alors on va reprendre point par point si
vous le voulez bien le localisme et un
vj ben je crois que vous en êtes un peu
à l'initiative dans le programme de
marine le pen alors tout le monde
forcément est d'accord produit et
consommé français au maximum avec cet
objectif de 80% produits français dans
les cantines la question c'est comment
on y parvient très concrètement tout en
restant dans le marché commun chez lui
que vous vouliez rester dans le marché
commun de l'union européenne mais avec
des barrières douanières ou ça a quel
frontière a expliqué nous je vous
rassure elle n'est pas question de
mettre des fronts intérieures de
l'europe bloquer les produits il est
question de redonner son pouvoir de
choix aux consommateurs en informant et
en sollicitant cette préférence que je
crois nous vivons tous près de chez nous
quand ça nous est possible a pris à peu
près équivalent nous préférons acheter
des produits des fruits des légumes de
la viande et s'est produit près de chez
nous
le cadre dans lequel s'inscrit notre
projet il n'est pas d'abord économique
c'est d'abord un retour de la démocratie
nous voulons restituer toute leur place
aux enquêtes d'utilité publique nous
voulons restituer toute leur place tout
simplement au choix des riverains je ne
sais pas s'il faut démanteler toutes les
tous les parcs éoliens gizeh qu'il faut
consulter les riverains je ne sais pas
s'il faut arrêter des projets de
méthanisation je sais qu'il faut
consulter des riverains je sais qu'il
faut réhabiliter le rôle du commissaire
denquête l'enquêteur public il
établissait un rapport qui permettait
aux associations de se prononcer je
souhaiterais pour ma part à ce volet
sur la préférence nationale des des
produits alimentaires locales d'accord
mais comment vous faites parce que
aujourd'hui voilà on est dans un monde
ouvert est ce que j'ai pu lire ils
seront regardés d'ailleurs dans
différents livrets c'est pas toujours
facile de se retrouver dans le programme
de marine le pen
en gros elle voudrait au fond interdire
les produits en tous cas les désinciter
avec des barrières douanières les
produits alimentaires alors on sait pas
si ces étrangers à l'extérieur de
l'europe européen quand tu ne respectent
pas les normes ou quand on peut en
cultiver en france c'est vrai c'est faux
comment ça fonctionne vous allez faire
rétablir un certain nombre de faussetés
sur notre programme européen
naturellement que nous restons dans
l'union européenne naturellement nous
restons dans le grand marché de l'union
européenne nous souhaitons simplement
que les contrôles aux frontières soit
effectif les contrôles aux frontières
extérieures de l'union européenne
ensuite le localisme repose comme je les
dis sur le choix du consommateur accord
partout ils sont sollicités moi j'ai la
chance de fréquenter de village dans
deux provinces françaises différentes
dans chacun de ces villages le café
brasserie du coin s'est mis à publier
une ardoise avec tous les producteurs ce
qui est très intéressant c'est qu'on
constate que chaque fois que les
consommateurs ont le choix eh bien ils
choisissent d'acheter la volaille de
l'élevage de ils choisissent d'acheter
la viande de l'éleveur locales etc etc
donc c'est du simple incantation vous
il faut simplement que le consommateur
soit informé il faut qu'ils aient droit
à une information de qualité à cet égard
les qr codes peuvent nous donner nous
donner un grand service parce que le qr
code a cette vertu merveilleuse c'est
qu'il permet aux consommateurs d'avoir
une infinité d'informations sur le
produit qu'ils achètent mes gars si on
laisse le choix aux français quand même
des frontières parce qu'on les liens
dans le programme aille à un contrôle
des marchandises aux frontières
extérieures de l'europe pour faire que
ce qui ne pourrait pas être produit à
l'intérieur de l'europe ne rentre pas en
europe nous assistons à trop
d'importations frauduleuses sous des
prétextes et sous des formes diverses de
produits qu'ils n'auraient jamais pu
être récoltés cultiver ou exploités en
europe à ça il faut il faire barrage au
monde c'est au fond la question de la
souveraineté alimentaire qui est en jeu
tout le monde utilise cette expression
est ce qu'elle est souhaitable jusqu'où
est surtout possible parce que on est
quand même dans un monde ouvert on se
rend compte qu'on est très dépendant par
exemple des ongrais du colza aujourd'hui
avec la guerre en ukraine ça on peut
s'en déprendre mai mais jusqu'où en fait
la question posée à la base de ce débat
c'est quelle est la vision écologique et
la souveraineté alimentaire la défense
d'une agriculture locale française ça
fait partie de nos objectifs c'est ce
pourquoi nous nous battons au ministère
de l'agriculture et c'est la défense de
la france dans la politique agricole
commune mais c'est un tout petit morceau
du sujet de l'enjeu écologique et
climatique là on parle de notre capacité
à respecter l'accord de paris de notre
capacité à répondre aux attentes des
scientifiques du giec pour essayer
d'éviter que le réchauffement climatique
et lieux et bien sûr l'agriculture y est
à sa part à la fois dans les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre et dans la
biodiversité mais le gros du sujet c'est
quand même le gros de la peu du sujet de
la production énergétique à et venait en
fait ce que propose le rassemblement
national sait à peu près rien sur
l'énergie et puis je trouve qu'il ya
quand même une contradiction c'est le
localisme alors dans ce cas là c'est de
la production d'énergie partout en
france et la production d'énergie
partout en france elle est renouvelable
donc c'est le solaire et c'est aussi
l'éolien donc le localisme sans
production d'énergie en france cela
revient à dépendre du gaz et du pétrole
qui viennent de russie qui viennent du
moyen orient donc c'est totalement
incohérent chesnais sur la question
énergétique un mot là-dessus et
humoriste localisme qui est ma question
est à la fois sur l'énergie et sur ce
fameux localisme qu'est ce que c'est
pour l'un et pour l'autre votre
définition de la souveraineté parce que
la souveraineté alimentaire la
souveraineté énergétique autant de
définitions qui lie à d'analystes du
sujet donc je suis assez curieux de
savoir comment vous délimiter cette idée
de la souveraineté comment vous la
définissez l'un et l'autre la
souveraineté pour moi c'est la
possibilité de dépendre le plus possible
d'une capacité de production nationale
ou européenne parce que pour moi la
souveraineté est à la fois française et
européenne on est dans un grand marché
et si vous parlez de contrôles aux
frontières en fait vous êtes ambiguë
entre les contrôles aux frontières à
l'intérieur de l'union européenne et à
l'extérieur donc pour moi la
souveraineté elle est à la fois
française et européenne et en matière
agricole comme en matière énergétique ça
veut dire être en capacité de produire
pour répondre à nos besoins en français
et en europe et un régime la
souveraineté alimentaire est ce que
c'est ramener toute la production de
dorota classement j'étais très intéressé
par le concept d'autonomie stratégique
que le président emmanuel macron nous a
présenté à strasbourg en session
plénière du parlement européen en
revanche je pense que la question de
souveraineté européenne n'a pas de sens
la souveraineté appartient au peuple ou
nation il n'y a pas de peuple européen
il n'y a pas de nation européenne on
peut souhaiter qu'il en advienne une ce
sera probablement dans une génération
sur la question de le révoquer ça
consiste à mener toute la production
allemands sur la piste de souveraineté
ça consiste essentiellement à décider
nous mêmes de ce qui nous concerne la
vous m'avez posé la question du
localisme le localisme c'est tout
simplement le rêve européen la
subsidiarité la subsidiarité c'est un
mot qui était partout dans les
institutions européennes dans les années
80 et 90 et c'est un mot qui a disparu
la subsidiarité si on met au niveau le
plus bas possible plus près du terrain
possible l'essentiel de la décision
qui dépend de l'hôpital je vous
rejoindrai volontiers là dessus par
exemple il y a des points d'autonomie
stratégique qu'on n'aura pas au niveau
national on peut les avoir qu'au niveau
européen et ça nous l'acceptons
totalement dans notre prochaine
naturellement des questions de défense
nous serions beaucoup plus forts si nous
arrivions à construire une défense
européenne alors là
votre
voulait pas entendre parler d'une les
champs sur un tir vers la chine sont
très compromise la souveraineté c'est
quand on décide nous mêmes de ce qui
nous concerne ça peut d'ailleurs être de
choisir des chaînes d'approvisionnement
qu'on maîtrise hors des frontières alors
on va essayer d'entrer dans le détail
puisque vous avez commencé à parler de
la question énergétique
on va commencer par ce qui vous oppose
le plus le renouvelable hervé juvin
moratoire sur les éoliennes et
démantèlement de celle qui existe déjà
est-ce que c'est pas franchement un peu
démagogique quand on veut respecter les
accords de paris de se priver de
l'éolien tout simplement nous nous
sommes engagés à respecter les accords
de paris simplement nous souhaitons que
la france définit sa propre trajectoire
et j'observe que dans la trajectoire
définie par l'union européenne beaucoup
de choses sont en train de changer
c'est la neutralité carbone en 2050 un
parfaitement affecteront la neutralité
carbone ne marchera pas 100 et le lien
et 100 solaire je vous entends je vous
dis que si nous parvenons à nous le
souhaitons à redonner à la france ses
pleines capacités nucléaires si nous
parvenons à réaliser un mix énergétique
qui fera beaucoup plus appel dans
l'avenir au biogaz à l'hydrogène à la
géothermie etc qui aura une part aux
renouvelables nous n'allons pas exclure
les renouvelables du mix énergétique
donc pas la
peine c'est que comme je voulais dit ça
fait partie du localisme nous
redonnerons le pouvoir aux habitants de
leur territoire sur ce qui se passe sur
leur territoire j'étais avant-hier dans
la région du mans j'étais avec un couple
de retraités un jeune ménage qui attend
son premier enfant qui ont acheté des
maisons on les a réformé sur rien ils
vont être entre un méthaniseur et un
parc d'éoliennes sans qu'ils soient
consultés sans qu'ils aient eu leur mot
à dire ça ça nous semble inacceptable le
démantèlement des parcs d'éoliennes et
bien nous donnerons la parole aux
habitants du territoire est nouvelle à
la faisabilité vous confondez la méthode
est l'objectif l'objectif c'est l'accord
de paris l'accord de paris l'a été
transcrit en droit français dans un
texte appelle la stratégie nationale bas
carbone
est en train d'être rediscuter à
l'échelle européenne
dans un objectif ambitieux qui s'appelle
fit for fifty five c'est à dire
atteindre une réduction des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre de 55 % en 2030
pour ça on a besoin de plus de nucléaire
je pense que c'est le seul point sur
lequel nous sommes d'accord et de plus
de renouvelable dans le renouvelable
aujourd'hui l'éolien et le solaire faut
en gros 10 % de notre production
d'électricité
mais nadine veut multiplier par dix lits
faucons des rebonds contre lewis parc
éolien il faut qu'on aille plus vite sur
le solaire et sur l'éolien vous disent
on vous dit on peut s'en passer
hydroélectricité et biogaz d'abord
l'hydroélectricité on a à peu près
saturé toute notre capacité de
production et ensuite le biogaz vous
venez de nous expliquer que la
méthanisation c'est pas une bonne
nouvelle or le biogaz aux dernières
nouvelles ça vient bien de la
méthanisation vous nous dites c'est la
méthode mais il faut une volonté
politique
bien sûr que la méthode doit nécessiter
une concertation est d'ailleurs le
président de la république l'a dit il
faut concerter au maximum et après
essayer d'accélérer les délais quand la
concertation a abouti mais sans
volontarisme on n'y arrivera pas vous ne
serez y avait sur la page sur l'éolien
c'est évident mais il ya aussi des
endroits
oui c'est ce que j'ai toujours dit j'ai
l'occasion chaque semaine ou à peu près
de prendre le tgv entre paris et
bruxelles nous avons une zone
d'entrepôts logistiques ligne de tgv
autoroutes infrastructures diverses là
ça ne me gêne pas beaucoup qui est des
parcs d'éoliennes et d'ailleurs il y en
a quand vous mettez un parc d'éoliennes
en mer entre l'île d'yeu et lou l'île de
noirmoutier qui l'a privé des pêcheurs
artisanaux parmi les derniers en france
tu as de leurs champs de pêche
privilégiée dans des conditions
techniques qui sont extrêmement
difficile extrêmement incertaines donc à
coup incertain là je dis casse cou
je voulais sur l'objectif vous répondrez
madame le ministre sur le qui a supprimé
une grande partie des recours qui a
supprimé une grande partie des enquêtes
d'utilité publique qui a supprimé la
capacité des associations écologistes à
s'opposer à des projets d'éolien et
d'éolien en mer est-ce que vous avez
rencontré les associations qui se
battent contre le parc d'éoliennes à
saint brieuc est-ce que vous avez
rencontré les pêcheurs de noirmoutier
l'île yeux comme je lé fais qui se bat
contre le parc éolien vous leur avez à
peu près supprimer tous les retours
vous avez vous avez remplacé le
commissaire enquêteur par des
dispositifs internet où il n'y a pas de
rapport et où il est extrêmement
difficile ensuite d'aller plaider ça
vous avez bloqué la démocratie locale à
poste vous allait supprimer la capacité
des français de soutenir des projets 3
instruisent leurs rivaux de recours donc
on est passé de 3,3 niveau des ambitions
plus à bas au niveau juridique afin de
faire manche il a durablement continuer
à exister dans un déni de démocratie
locale ou moi j'ai enlevé le pouvoir
français sur les collèges et lycées
nationale qui détruisent notre
territoire ça c'est je vois pas ce que
ça vient faire là dedans et par ailleurs
nous notre objectif c'est d'avoir une
filière industrielle ya pas de lien
aujourd'hui le président aussi mince ses
sims gazza au havre dans une usine qui
est une usine d'éoliennes nous allons
réimplanter des gigas factory pour les
batteries donc nous sommes en train de
réinvestir dans une cape à n'y a rien
personnellement dans le canada manuel
macron était le plus hostile et
l'écologie et n'ont jamais connu on a
des trous viser la france vous détruisez
les territoires joie de vivre des
français sont priés de rester ce sujet
par saison mais c'est quand même les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre le
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron a été
celui dans lequel la réduction des gaz à
effet de serre et la plus importante on
a baissé de 12% en un quinquennat on
faisait 1 % par an en moyenne avant donc
c'est factuellement font donner la
parole quinquennat n'a pas permis
d'avancer sur l'écologie emmanuel dans
les faits les trois quarts des projets
d'implantation d'éoliennes en france
donne lieu à un contentieux des
riverains et c'est vrai qu'il ya un
problème d'acceptabilité dans l'est dans
les territoires des projets d'éolien
comment est-ce qu'on peut passer au
dessus de ça parce qu'on a l'impression
qu'on a quand même vraiment beaucoup
construit d'éoliennes dans le territoire
et que ça devient difficilement
acceptable et qu'effectivement ce
problème de recours
est un problème je reviens souvent sur
la table alors il ya un objectif tout le
monde l'a bien compris il ya des moyens
et comment est ce qu'on fait coïncider
les deux parce que quand on s'aperçoit
que les citoyens effectivement aucun
problème avec les éoliennes quand on
parle aux maires des petites communes il
explique que c'est compliqué pour eux je
pense que la bonne réponse elle est dans
deux éléments le premier c'est la
planification
c'est à dire de définir en liaison avec
les élus quelles sont les zones dans
lesquelles c'est envisageable
d'implanter des éoliennes ou d'ailleurs
des panneaux solaires ou d'ailleurs de
la méthanisation versus des zones dans
lesquelles c'est plus compliqué et que
cette planification elles soient
négociés entre les élus et l'état et
après moi j'en ai vu beaucoup des
projets d'éoliennes des endroits
laquelle ça se passait bien des endroits
dans lesquels il y avait des contentieux
là où ça se passe bien c'est par exemple
j'ai un exemple dans le doubs
d'éoliennes participative où en réalité
dès le début les citoyens on était très
associé au projet même y compris
financièrement aux prenant des parts
dans un projet qui va bénéficier
directement à la collectivité et là il
ya une fierté est là il ya une
appropriation du projet à les autres je
partage tout à fait l'idée que ça ne
doit pas se faire contre les accablant
mais avec mais on a les moyens de le
faire on va parler du nucléaire en
revanche de quorum en avant sur le
méthaniseur si vous voulez qu'on aborde
d'autres sujets il va falloir faire un
petit peu plus court le nucléaire vous
êtes d'accord en revanche simplement
vous voulez chacun construire six
nouveaux apn mais marine le pen veut
rouvrir la centrale de fessenheim vous
avez suivi ce dossier de près et
emmanuelle wargon hervé juvin est ce que
c'est possible honnêtement de revenir en
arrière edf affirme le contraire les
réacteurs ont été mises à l'arrêt la
centrale est démantelé il ya dix ans de
travaux non réalisés est-ce que ça se
rattrape escaut nettement on peut dire à
ceux qui nous regardent on va rouvrir
fessenheim voté pour nous ce n'est pas
simple techniquement mais ça a été un
gâchis la sister ship de neil stein qui
est installé aux états unis a vu sa
durée de vie prolongée et vérifiés par
l'autorité internationale jusqu'en 2046
c'est un gâchis d'avoir fait d'avoir
filmé et maintenant dit qu'aujourd'hui
écrit dans le programme environnement
achevé toutes les études nécessaires à
la réouverture de fessenheim mais si
c'est possible nous rio vous dire on
fait 100 m nl barca n'est pas possible
il faut pas mentir aux français
ça n'est pas possible de rouvrir
fessenheim techniquement
industriellement ce qui s'est passé avec
cette centrale c'est que depuis 2012 sa
fermeture a été annoncée comme sa
fermeture a été annoncée les travaux de
grand carénage les travaux de
renouvellement par décennie n'ont jamais
été lancé et donc dès 2017 2018 au début
du quinquennat d'emmanuel macro ont fait
c'était déjà trop tard pour lancer les
travaux permettant à cette centrale de
continuer à fonctionner elle était dans
un espèce d'entre d'eux dans laquelle
elle était maintenue ouverte avec des
autorisations provisoires mais
finalement on sent que les
investissements étaient faits et donc
nous avons pris la décision d'aller au
bout de la décision précédente et de ne
pas la maintenir les investissements ou
été fait pour l'arrêter et ça n'est plus
possible de rouvrir fessenheim dont acte
on voit bien les lignes de fracture un
tout petit mot là dessus et puis on va
avancer sur le programmes des manuels
macron dans le détail on a bien compris
que le projet l'un est l'un et l'autre
de vos projets ou tenait la construction
de nouvelles centrales quid des
centrales qui sont dans dans le cas de
presque fessenheim c'est à dire dont on
n'a pas encore totalement décidé de la
fermeture ou la fermeture est programmée
mais pas forcément enclenché qu'est ce
que vous faites pour ses centrales là
d'abord on a un nombre important de
réacteurs aujourd'hui qui sont en arrêt
pour maintenance ou qui sont en arrêt
parce qu'il ya des travaux pas forcément
prévu à faire donc la première chose
c'est d'arriver à relancer notre
capacité de production nucléaire est
l'historique historiquement basses après
l'objectif est de pouvoir maintenir les
centrales en activité mais en regardant
à chaque fois si c'est possible ou si en
réalité la centrale en fauchant ce que
dit l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire n'est
pas en capacité de continuer ça ne se
décide pas en claquant des doigts qu'on
peut amener tous les réacteurs à 60 ans
ça n'est pas vrai les réacteurs ont été
construits pour 30 à 40 ans il est
possible qu'on puisse poursuivre faille
kernel ne sont pas éternels et
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on voit déjà
aujourd'hui qu'on n'a plus de
défaillances que ce qu'on souhaiterait
est la raison pour laquelle on est en
difficulté aujourd'hui c'est aussi parce
que notre production est historiquement
basses alors on va continuer à discuter
de ces deux projets qu'on voit vraiment
très différent sur des aspects on va
parler de la rénovation thermique parce
que ça
isoler les bâtiments ça peut se faire
beaucoup plus vite qu'une centrale qui
prêt qui prend trente ans être
construite on va regarder ce sujet de
marion becker sur le programme d'
emmanuel macron puis on va parler aussi
d'un mot parfois absent de votre
programme hervé juvin la sobriété
regarder ce sujet
à quelques jours du second tour emmanuel
macron veut enrichir son programme
écologique pour courtiser les électeurs
de jean luc mélenchon et de yannick
jadot je souhaite qu'on puisse regarder
ce qui dans les autres propositions
celles qui étaient faites par a aussi
monsieur jadot et d'autres candidats sur
quoi par exemple mettre sur les sujets
de d'économie circulaire de souhaite
regarder aussi ce qui venant d'autres
d'autres propositions à nous permettent
de clarifier cette ligne avec une
planification écologique qui pourra
mettre si je puis dire année après année
ces objets série des gens les prennent
en font mais je pense que la méthode est
bonne l'objectif intensifier ses propres
mesures et elle est plus vite vers la
transition écologique et pour cela le
président candidat a misé sur le
nucléaire fini l'objectif de 50% du
nucléaire dans la production électrique
promis en 2010 est son ambition c'est
désormais le chantier du siècle comme il
le nomme avec la construction des six
premières centrales nucléaires de
nouvelle génération
outre le nucléaire le candidat emmanuel
macron mise sur le solaire mais aussi
sur l'éolien hier au havre ils défendent
l implantation de 50 parc éolien en mer
d'ici 2050 sur le sujet de
l'environnement et du climat le projet
que nous portons et en l'espèce ce qui
est ici porté c'est une vraie solution
parce que on va déployer de l'éolien en
mer on va déployer du renouvelables pour
produire de manière décarbonés de
l'énergie eon va se faisant créer des
emplois aujourd'hui et demain il veut
également instaurer une taxe carbone aux
frontières de l'europe et propose une
offre de voitures électriques de
location à des prix abordables pour les
ménages les plus modestes
alors on va parler des transports mais
j'aimerais qu'on parle du bâtiment c'est
votre dossier le logement emmanuelle
wargon la question de la rénovation
thermique premier bilan et qu'est ce que
vous faites si emmanuel macron est réel
pour aller beaucoup plus loin beaucoup
plus fort alors la rénovation thermique
des bâtiments ça al'avantage d'être à la
fois bon pour la planète puisqu'on
consommant 1 m et moins de co2 est bon
pour le pouvoir d'achat parce qu'on
baisse les factures on l'a
considérablement développé pendant le
quinquennat c'est une de nos très belle
victoire avec 650 mille dossiers ma
prime rénove l'année dernière et une
amélioration des barèmes aujourd'hui
puisque aujourd'hui nous avons annoncé
qu'on rajoute 1000 euros dead pour tous
les changements de chaudières pour aller
vers des pompes à chaleur des chaudières
à bois granulés justement pour aller
encore plus vite dans la sortie de mode
de chauffage fossile gaz ou fioul vers
du chauffage renouvelable qui n'émet pas
de co2 donc là on a un gisement
important
on a montré qu'on savait faire
l'objectif précédent de tous les canards
précédent c'était au moins cinq cent
mille par an et on en a fait six cent
cinquante mille l'année dernière et sur
les îles qu'un général objectif c'est au
moins 700 mille par an et puis qu'on
aille progressivement vers des
rénovations encore plus ambitieuse que
celle que nous faisons mais déjà entre
l'aide précédente qui était un crédit
d'impôt et ma prime rénove on a
multiplié par deux le gain d'énergie
économisée par logement par travaux
effectués en régie 20 avec la guerre en
ukraine évidemment cette question de
notre dépendance au gaz allait elle est
fondamentale qu'est ce que vous proposez
et ont déjà la chance en france d'être
beaucoup moins dépendants du gaz russe
que ça mais bon
le gaz qu'ils soient russes ou pas ça
change des grandes chances la question
des économies d'énergie elle et je
reviendrai volontiers ce que vous avez
dit sur fit for fifty five vous n'êtes
pas sans ignorer qu'il va falloir revoir
fit for fifty-five parce qu'il ya une
confusion dramatique faite par l'union
européenne c'est pas parce qu'on
consomme plus d'énergie si elle est
décarbonée qu'on va sortir plus de
carbone fif toi la vie au confort que
vous dites si on sort moins décarbonés
on m ait moins de carbone on peut
consommer plus d'énergie décarbonnée
sans augmenter notre consommation de
carbone nous ne faisons pas d'illusions
par les raisons de sécurité pour des
raisons de confort 55 % de réduction
d'émissions de co2 donc fine on dans le
texte on confond la consommation globale
d'énergie avec l'émanation de carbone
nous aurons besoin de plus d'énergie y
compris pour répondre à nos besoins de
sécurité parce que l'invasion russe
si on a évidemment
mais on ne peut pas appliquer fit fils
faure fifty-five dans les termes définis
par l'union européenne va alors là c'est
sur la taxonomie ils veulent il va
falloir en sorte là c'est sur la place
de l'énergie polluante dans le pacte
européen sur versements de thermique par
dans ce que monsieur juin nous dit c'est
l'ambition européenne elle est pas bonne
elle est pas souhaitable d'ailleurs
allez pas possible donc il faut
renégocier à la baisse les ambitions
européennes je pense que ça c'est un
point fondamental de désaccord nous nous
souhaitons tenir la corde paris nous
souhaitons tenir zéro émission de
carbone en 2050 et ça passe par 55 %
d'émissions en moins en 2030 d'une
certaine manière vous est clair vous
voulez sortir de la corde sortir de
l'union dans leur programme cas de la
vision européenne du sujet elle veut
marine le pen où on voit bien sur les
engagements internationaux qu'elle
considère irraisonnée elle veut revenir
au rythme qu'elle choisit donc on sent
bien que cette question c'est un enjeu
de cette question voilà aussi de la
centrale
nous avons conscience et d'écologie nous
avions consenti d abandon ne pouvoir
considérable y compris dans le cadre du
green deal en acceptant une taxonomie de
vous savez qu'à l'origine les autres
années les questions sur sa capacité à
respecter la guilde et finiront notre
propre trajectoire c'est très clair
emmanuel ducrocq à celle sur les
économies d'énergie mais justement je
voulais savoir si le mot sobriété avait
une traduction dans votre programme ou
si vous considérez simplement qu'on peut
augmenter la capella la consommation
d'énergie décarbonée est ce que le mot
sobriété trouve une traduction quelque
part le moose ouvriers été trouvé une
traduction simplement il est difficile
de dire à certaines aux électeurs ont du
mal à la fois payer leur loyer à se
chauffer et à manger qu'ils doivent
aller vers plus de sobriété je ne peux
que saluer les efforts pour financer les
pompes à chaleur pour financer la
transition énergétique mais notre
électeurs pour notre électorat dont
certains ont du mal comme je le dis à se
nourrir convenablement à se chauffer et
c'est ce mot
sort de paris c'est aussi par la
souriante rendez vous demande le monde
est d'accord là dessus parce que moi je
considère et bien sûr le candidat
considèrent que la réduction de la
consommation dans les bâtiments la
rénovation qui permet de moins consommer
le passage à une voiture électrique avec
un leasing à un prix abordable qui
pourrait être d'environ 100 euros par
mois ça conjugue la sobriété consommer
moins et dépenser moins donc il n'ya pas
de contradiction sur tous les sujets en
trois saisons celle de l'efficacité de
la sobriété vélo le train ça c'est de là
c'est exactement on a besoin des deux on
a besoin d'efficacité énergétique et on
a besoin de sobriété et donc
d'alternative la place de la voiture
pour bien comprendre dans dans le
l'écologie de marine le pen on a
l'impression que pour elle c'est
vraiment le véhicule d'avenir est ce que
le moteur thermique a de beaux jours
devant lui si elle est élue
nos électeurs ont besoin de leur voiture
pour travailler ils ont besoin de leur
voiture pour se déplacer
la majorité de nos électeurs vous savez
bien sont en zone rurale on a assisté à
une grande rupture entre la france de
ceux qui sont dans les aéroports ceux
qui n'ont pas besoin de la voiture pour
travailler pour se déplacer et ceux pour
qui la voiture c'est un besoin quotidien
à ceux là qui ont très peur de ne plus
pouvoir entrer dans les agglomérations à
cela qu'ils se sentent exclus à ceux là
qui sentent un mécanisme d'exclusion
sociale parce que les zones à faibles
émissions des centre-villes c'est des
zones à fortes exclusion ceux là ont
peur ceux là ont peur de ce qui leur
arrive que des prétextes divers et nous
voulons rompre avec une écologie
punitive je pense que le drame de
l'écologie politique du score de
monsieur jadot c'est tout simplement
qu'on ne fera pas l'écologie en
punissant les gens et nous avons très
peur d'un certain discours qui est en
train de fâcher en profondeur les
français du diagnostic la question c'est
le comment emmanuel dupont c-max et ma
question c'est très bien ce constat
effectivement de l'exclusion des
centres-villes et de la dépendance à
l'automobile en zone rurale c'est un
constat qui est bien connu on sait aussi
qu'on peut pas effectivement punir les
gens dans leur quotidien mais est ce
qu'on peut leur proposer des
alternatives
est-ce que vous avez
modéliser quelques alternatives à
l'utilisation de la voiture individuelle
pour je ne sais pas massifier une
particule transport pour voilà est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire comment vous
pouvez apporter aussi une réponse à ces
gens plutôt de dire on acte le fait que
vous êtes dépendant de votre voiture
quelques mots parce qu'il faut conclure
je vous répondrai en deux en deux temps
d'abord dans le conseil régional des
pays de la loire dont je suis membre
nous avons souscrit à tous les efforts
pour multiplier les lignes de trains
régionaux pour réouvrir des guichets ré
ouvrir des lignes intensifier le trafic
avec des horaires finale nationale dans
le programme national c'est la même
chose ré ouvrir des lignes secondaires
retravaillé offert routage au transport
de camions sur par voies ferrées etc le
second point de réponse et nous nous
rapprocherons là dessus c'est de
favoriser là le retour de l'habitation
centre-ville en coeur de ville en coeur
de village nous ne pouvons plus
continuer avec un mitage qui est
extrêmement coûteux en énergie qui est
coûteux en infrastructures il faut
inciter les français à réinvestir le
coeur de village le coeur de ville il
ramenait des commerces de l'artisanat de
l'activité s'ils n'ont plus besoin de
prendre leur voiture pour aller
travailler d'accord là on aura gagné
beaucoup de choses le mot de la fin très
rapidement et managers mois sur ce
dernier point sur réinvestir les
centres-villes centre village est centre
bourg je suis d'accord on l'a d'ailleurs
largement commencé avec le programme
action coeur de ville ensuite il me
semble que la voiture il ne faut pas
l'opposé aurait semé effectivement notre
objectif c'est de trouver des
alternatives et de proposer des
alternatives sur les petites lignes de
train bien sûr mais aussi sur le
covoiturage mais aussi sur le vélo et la
possibilité de ce qu'on appelle
l'intermodalité c'est à dire de pouvoir
utiliser différents types de transport
pour pouvoir avancer et après vous avez
beaucoup parlé de vos électeurs
le président de la république le
candidat il ne s'adresse pas qu'à ses
électeurs il s'adresse à tous les
français il cherche à répondre aux
besoins de tous les français merci on va
s'arrêter là je pense que voilà les
différents projets les différentes
visions sont très claires j'espère que
vous y verrez un peu plus clair pour
faire leur votre votre choix dimanche
prochain merci infiniment emmanuel du
gros hervé juvin emmanuelle wargon ou va
accueillir à présent notre grand témoin
elles travaillent sur les réseaux de
marine le pen depuis des années elle a
publié un livre il y a dix ans très
fouillée sur sa stratégie de
dédiabolisation dix ans après comment
expliquer que marine le pen rassemble
aujourd'hui près de 8 millions de voix
sans compter d'ailleurs celle d'eric
zemmour qui vont sans doute se reporter
sur elle le 24 avril prochain en a plein
de questions à poser à caroline fourest
comme les skis ce sujet de marque au
premier
si on vous invite caroline fourest c'est
parce que marine le pen et tout ce
groupe de la présidentielle plus dé
diaboliser que jamais alors une question
ce soir la candidate du rassemblement
national et l d'extrême droite nos deux
finalistes ont leur petite idée quand je
vois les sans droits de caila serait
faux de dire que madame le pen qui
explique que le voile serait interdit
qu'on n'aurait pas le droit de manger
halal ou casher ou que ce succès serai
la présidente de tous les français
soyons clairs je conteste formellement
cette cette formulation d'extrême-droite
qui correspond à des choses extrêmement
précises qui ne correspond à nier au
projet politique
d'eric zemmour et encore moins
bien caroline fourest vous êtes
essayiste réalisatrice mais aussi
journaliste à franc-tireur hebdomadaire
qui porte la raison comme étendard
polynice t'engager vous militez contre
les intégrismes religieux et les
extrémismes politiques le cas de marine
le pen vous vous y êtes intéressé de
près vous dit l'avoir démasqué on
retiendra votre débat tendu avec elle
c'était en 2011 sur un concept cher à la
candidate la préférence nationale quand
des français de culture musulmane
s'engage pour servir l'armée française
et pour servir la france qu'est ce qui
vous permet d'affirmer qu'ils sont de
mauvaise qualité je gère madame forest
monsieur pascal boniface qui a écrit un
livre qui s'appelle les intellectuels
faussaires vous y avait un bel espace
d'ailleurs
serial menteuse et bien ce que vous
venez de dire est un mensonge dans les
nombreuses et nommé la marine le pen et
les journalistes une relation souvent
compliqué mais aujourd'hui le débat est
ouvert de la pestiférée à la meilleur
ami des chats at elle vraiment changé
évolution sincère ou campagne de
dissimulation sur le papier les idées
les plus radicales ont été remisés au
placard sortie de l'euro rétablissement
de la peine de mort opération ravalement
de façade sur la forme aussi exclusion
du père encombrant des militants les
moins présentables enfin pas tous les
cabinets de conseils de marine le pen
les français ne les connaissent pas et
là on n'est pas en train de parler de ma
kiné ou de capgemini ou je ne sais pas
on est en train de parler du gud c'est
juste l'école la plus radicale de
l'extrême droite française or les
membres du sud on les retrouve à tous
les étages des postes clés capitaux du
rassemblement national alors caroline
fourest selon vous qui incarne l'extrême
droite dans cette campagne
présidentielle de marine le pen
tel achevé sa normalisation et ce bon
vieux front républicain est il toujours
d'actualité
nous attendons vos réponses
bonsoir caroline forest et merci
enchaînement d'être avec nous vos
directrice éditoriale de francs-tireurs
hebdomadaire qui titre cette semaine sur
les 10 raisons de bloquer le marine le
pen et pourtant ils sont plus de 8
millions avoir voté pour elle elle a
beaucoup évolué et marine le pen sur la
forme évidemment mais sur le fond aussi
elle veut plus sortir de l'europe elle
veut plus sortir de l'euro elle se
soucie de la dette aujourd'hui même
d'ailleurs elle considère que
l'interdiction du voile dans la rue mais
plus une mesure si essentiel vous ne lui
faites crédit d'aucune forme de
sincérité
évidemment qu'on finit tous par évoluer
avec le temps bien sûr qu'elle a sans
doute en partie évolué mais la stratégie
qui consiste à avoir un discours attrape
tout qui varie selon l'air du temps et à
dissimuler la radicalité de son projet
c'est une stratégie que son père avait
déjà ça a toujours été la stratégie du
front national son père était juste
moins doués parce que par moments il ne
pouvait pas s'empêcher de montrer une
part de vérité on va venir peut-être
là-dessus parce qu'on l'a oublié c'est
les années 80 jean marie le pen voulait
dédiaboliser bien sûr normalisé
finalement qu'est ce qui se passe
pourquoi il n'y parviens pas je vous
donne un exemple bien mais juste avant
son son dérapage sur le point de détail
et sur les chambres à gaz il revient
d'une tournée aux états unis où il est
allé voir des organisations juives en
leur tenant un discours extrêmement
sioniste au même moment son parti est
truffé de négationniste de collabo
d'anciens nostalgiques de vichy ça
n'empêche pas jean marie le pen d'aller
devant des organisations juives dire je
suis avec vous je suis sioniste et boum
patatras ensuite il dérape sur les
chambres à gaz
marine le pen honnêtement a évidemment
des pas de la même génération ils
pensent sans doute pas la même chose que
son père sur les chambres à gaz pour de
vrai on veut en revanche dans son parti
dans son entourage proche et encore une
fois je parle de portes de postes clés
je parle pas des clampins des lampistes
qu'on envoie sur les plateaux de télé
pour faire illusion je parle des gens
qui tiennent l'appareil c qui alors
parce que c'est vrai que c'est votre
apport à toutes les enquêtes qui est
sont nombreuses sur sur marine le pen
votre livre a été publié il ya dix ans
environ déjà il était là
vent qui sont ils ces amis proches ses
conseillers de l'ombre issu de l'école
de l'extrême droite la plus forte la
plus classique le réseau le plus
clairement implanté dans aux postes clés
dissimulé du front national ce sont tous
des anciens du gud le but c'est vraiment
alors c'est l'extrême nord est la plus
extrême droite qui unitaire
des directs de défense ou et des franges
succès défense c'est vous avez ils ont
cet emblème qui est la croix celtique le
rat noir c'est surtout les plus
antisémites de l'extrême droite c'est à
dire c'est des gens qui sont fascinés
par le nationalisme arabe par bachar
el-assad aujourd'hui ils sont su
fasciner par poutine bien sûr mais
surtout il se rapproche même des
islamistes par moments tellement ils ont
en commun avec eux de détester les juifs
et donc il ya toute une ribambelle
d'hommes qui si l'évolution était
sincère c'est à dire que si marine le
pen voulait vraiment débarrasser son
parti de ces gens là elle se serait
débarrassé de ces gens là pour ces
gens-là gens là ils ont qu'à l'
influence quelle place tiennent
l'essentiel c'est-à-dire qu'ils tiennent
les le micro parti de marine le pen
jeanne ils sont mouillés comment est-ce
qu'ils apparaissent aux yeux du grand
public est encore passé à mes yeux c'est
parce qu'ils sont impliqués dans toutes
les affaires de financement du front
national c'est eux qui sont en train de
prendre la beaucoup de risques pour le
parti il faut il faut mesurer qu'un
micro parti en l'occurrence le
micro-parti personnel de marine le pen
c'est même pas un vieux truc c'est le
micro parti de la candidate jeanne c'est
le porte clé c'est que comme on veut
dire c'est le porte-monnaie le plus
stratégie de 52 places que des légendes
or qui brille et sciences exactement et
valérie châtillon à celle loustau pardon
axel loustau il n'y a pas plus extrêmes
mourad ya pas plus radicale qu axel
loustau il n'a pas changé on le voit là
à l'image c'est quelqu'un qui a
participé avec philippe péninque
également très proche de la candidate
avec lequel elle a fait toute la purge
au moment de la fronde mais gré ce sont
des gens avec frédéric chatillon et
quelques autres qui ont été déportés le
mouvement d'alain soral égalité
réconcilier jacques benouw peut-être
pour ceux qui nous c'est là où le jeu
atelier là où le jus du resserrement
absolument incroyable c'est que pendant
que la candidature et vous dire égalité
réconciliation c'est le mouvement qui a
fait monter l'antisémitisme en banlieue
c'est le mouvement qui apprenaient le
front de la fois c'est à dire l'alliance
des chrétiens patriotes et des musulmans
radicaux
contre les juifs c'est ça égalité
réconciliation de soral et le but en
fait de la manoeuvre était quoi parce
que derrière ce rallye avait et
châtillon y avait philippe péninque il y
avait des gens comme tout la connexion
guide hard le but c'était de dire aux
banlieusards voter pour l'extrême droite
parce qu'elle est parce qu'au fond ils
vous le disent pas mais derrière ils
s'occuperont des juifs pendant que la
vitrine officielle du rassemblement
national dit en gros français votez pour
nous avec la préférence nationale vous
savez qu'on va se charger des musulmans
ce double discours là qui a toujours été
typique du front national est typique du
rassemblement national c'est juste notre
mémoire collective kbc c'est juste notre
vigilance collective qui a baissé c'est
qu'on n'arrive plus à voir qu'il s'agit
d'un jeu de dupes donc c'est l'extrême
droite c'est ce que met bien sûr que
c'est l'extrême droite elle récuse
l'étiquette vous savez elle met son père
l'a de droite patriote ondes nationales
mais jean marie le pen l'a récusé aussi
sauf que il ya quelques années quand
quelqu'un récusé une étiquette on
arrivait encore à travailler
suffisamment pour pouvoir lui dire
'attendez pardon il ya des preuves il ya
des faits la préférence nationale jean
marie le pen a aussi essayé de nous
faire croire qu'elle n'était en rien
raciste mais encore une fois on savait
qu'il y avait derrière ils ont appris et
quand même ils ont mis le temps parce
qu'ils ont eue marine le pen ça fait
trente ans qu'elle fait de la politique
trente ans qu'elle s'exerce à dissimuler
le projet de ce parti et il faut
comprendre aussi quelque chose de plus
personnel et ça je crois que c'est sa
vraie sincérité c'est que même quand
elle exclut son père même quand elle lui
fait de la peine au fond moi je suis
convaincu de sa elles veulent
réhabiliter mais pour ça elle a besoin
qui lui fiche la paix elle a besoin
qu'il soit pas tout le temps en train de
faire des sorties pas possible sur la
seconde guerre mondiale pour pouvoir
aller au bout de cette stratégie lui
montrer et le rendre fier lui montrer
qu'elle peut y arriver qu'elle est quand
même fifi on l'appeler fille fille dans
la famille le pen fille fille est quand
même elle a réussi deux trois choses et
sa première en vie elle l'a dit
récemment lady à trois jours et
d'interviews c'est que son père soit
l'elysée quand on aura le pouvoir parce
qu elle le fait aussi pour lui elle a
énormément souffert de voir son père
attaquer quand elle était jeune voici
même quelque chose qui me touche à son
sujet je pense vraiment que c'est sa
meilleure façon cette diabolisation de
réussir pour lui montrer qu'elle est à
la hauteur et ensuite habilité donc il
faut pas que les français se trompent si
marine le pen est présidente à des
cérémonies avec jean marie le pen on
aura même et rejouer une statue pour
jean marie le pen c'est pas une rupture
c'est juste le stratège l'avertissement
de caroline fourest conduisent aussi à
un mot du président candidat vous êtes
une grande défenseurs de la laïcité vous
avez beaucoup écrit sur la question du
voile sur la montée de l'islamisme ya
cette séquence que j'aimerais vous faire
commenté regarder
ah oui
bon discours
qui est beau il est féministe oui moi
j'y vais me disais pour l'égalité femmes
hommes je peux me permettre d'être
indiscret oui vous portez un brel par
choix s'est imposé ce
qu'est la caméra non je vous le dis par
avoir une jeune fille qui porte le voile
à strasbourg qui dit est ce que vous
êtes féministe c'est la meilleure des
réponses à toutes les bêtises que
j'entends parce que tout côté madame le
pen qui dirait vol sera interdit sur la
place publique avec moi il faut préciser
quand même que cette scène elle se
déroule en début de semaine à strasbourg
qui n'est pas une ville comme les autres
un vil concordataire qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette séquence vous êtes
féministe et vous portez le voile par
choix oui mais moi je suis féministe et
je pense qu'on peut tout à fait porter
le voile par choix et que ça nous ça dit
quand même qu'on ne voit pas bien la
contradiction entre un signe distinctif
qui a été pensé pour distinguer les
hommes des femmes et même les femmes pur
des femmes impures et le fait de se dire
féministe mais la nature humaine est
ainsi faite que si vous voulez en fait
on ne naît pas forcément lucide et on
peut avoir des contradictions la
question c'est est-ce que qu'est ce que
dit cette séquence du président de la
république est ce que c'est le rôle d'un
président de la république quand une
citoyenne vous tend la main et vous
sourit d'aller lui dire madame je n'aime
pas ce que vous portez sur la tête et je
n'aime pas ce que vous pensez je pense
que ça là ça révélerait un caractère
autoritaire je suis moi plutôt heureuse
que l'on j'espère qu'on va garder des
gouvernants qui ne soit pas autoritaire
mais j'ai beaucoup critiquent emmanuel
macron lorsqu'il a commencé sa campagne
de la dernière fois sur le fait que
justement je pensais qu'il était trop
naïf sur ces questions
je continue à penser que le président
peu de temps en temps au nom de la
volonté de réconcilier les français
d'apaiser ces questions d'être peut-être
un peu trop angélique
mais les grands pas et les claques
antennes est angélique dans sa réponse
au parc de la vallée
elle est ancienne mais je voudrais pas
que ça trompe les français sur la
réalité de sa politique parce qu'il ya
une chose sur lequel j'ai changé d'avis
- sur emmanuel macron en le voyant
gouverner et notamment depuis le
discours des muro notamment depuis
l'assassinât de sa mère pattie sais que
je suis bien obligé de reconnaître que
ce président au fond à la bonne
stratégie c'est à dire tenir un discours
national plutôt apaisant et je préfère
ça à quelqu'un qui crierait du soir au
matin sur le voile mais qui en coulisse
ferait l inverse de ce qu'il faut contre
l'islamisme or en coulisses et les
français à mon avis ne le voient passer
en coulisses ce gouvernement il a
dissout baraka city le collectif contre
l'islamophobie
le collectif du sheikh yassine il a voté
une loi utile contre le séparatisme
islamiste qui a valu à maignaut macron
d'être extrêmement menacée les menaces
qui venait de la turquie les menaces
contre les représentants de la france
ont été très sérieuse un moment donné
après patty ce que je veux dire c'est
que concrètement quand il s'agit d'être
efficace il a tenu bon donc c'est du et
en même temps la kiffer louis mais si
jackson oui mais ça c'est dur même temps
de la complexité parce que je préfère
encore une fois franchement mais
vraiment et je le dis et je partage cet
avis avec des gens qui sont sous
protection policière qui se bat comme
moi depuis 20 ans contre l'islamisme
nous sommes un certain nombre à mettre
sifaoui d'autres a préféré mille fois
des gouvernants responsable
apaisant au niveau national mais qui
mène une politique efficace contre le
séparatisme islamistes à des politiques
tonitruant qui vont vouloir nous clivé
nous polarisé dussourd matin sur la
question du voile et qui vont faire
monter le discours victimaire dont se
nourrit le recrutement il se lavait vous
coupez créé sur la manière dont marine
le pen instrumentalise la laïcité
aujourd'hui même elle dit qu'au fond
cette mesure du l'interdiction du port
du voile dans la rue n'est plus
forcément si essentiel que ça ça vient
percuter cette séquence oui enfin et
marine le pen ne sait a expliqué andrew
qu'elle voudrait faire comme bourguiba
président l'algérie je rappelle qu'il
était président de la tunisie et je
rappelle que c'était beaucoup plus plus
compliqué que c'était une autre époque
aujourd'hui concrètement mais c'est
toujours pareil chaque fois qu'elle met
une mesure sa frappe les esprits ça fait
plaisir et ça défoule mais concrètement
ça ne provoque que des problèmes si vous
interdisez le voile simple dans la rue
demain vous allez mobiliser des forces
de l'ordre n'ont en plus elles valent
elle va réduire leurs effectifs mais
vous allez mobiliser des policiers pour
arrachez dévoile dans les rues créer des
situations de tension vous allez faire
un corpus haïr les policiers vous allez
faire monter l'islamisme pour gagner
quoi parce que ça n'est même pas laïque
rappelez vous au moment de la loi de
1905 a eu des grands débats parmi les
défenseurs de la séparation est-ce qu'il
fallait ou non interdire la soutane dans
la rue qui était à l'époque un drapeau
de l'église catholique contre la laïcité
il est laïque sincère c'est à dire pas
ce qu'ils voulaient faire de la
surenchère gratuites ont dit non c'est
ridicule on va pas interdire les
soutanes dans la rue c'est ces
contre-performances vouloir interdire le
voile simple dans la rue mais toutes les
mesures du rassemblement national sur
l'islamisme sont non seulement
uniquement fait pour défouler mais sont
en réalité un régal pour les islamistes
en face je voudrais connaître votre
sentiment pour terminer sur au fond là
prêt et lectures ya trois blocs au fond
aujourd'hui cette extrême droite la
droite radicale le centre le grand
centre macro nhien et la gauche dite
populaire de jean luc mélenchon extrême
gauche de certains diront ça donne un
pays ingouvernable
non mais on sait que ce sera très
difficile tant qu'on n'est pas un peu
donc on recompose pas le paysage
politique sur la base d'idées claires et
d'incarnation clair les gens qui ont
voté pour jean luc mélenchon je pense
qu'ils ont eu un vote stratégique un
vote utile pour se dire que la préféré
avoir une affiche avec quelqu'un de
gauche au deuxième tour je le comprends
le problème c'est que maintenant comment
on fait pour recomposer la gauche
justement pour faire le tri du vote
sincère et du vote stratégique parce que
jean luc mélenchon personnellement - en
tant que personnes de gauche sur la
laïcité alors que j'ai fait des tribunes
avec lui on a tenu des conférences ont
semblé que jean luc mélenchon sur la
laïcité mais il a tellement changé il a
tellement travaillé sur ce sujet que
plus jamais - je ne peux me considérer
comme appartenant à cette gauche là en
raison des trahisons sur la laïcité donc
comment on fait pour recomposer à partir
d'un vote qui n'est pas si clair assez
clair ça va être difficile action qui
aurait dit ça va être facile demain mais
ce soit d'ailleurs le mais il ya un
immense enjeu de clarification pour
quand encore une fois d'abord les
français arrêtent de penser que leur
politique lormand ne font jamais rien
c'est pas vrai les politiques sont
plutôt sincère travail plutôt énormément
simplement on n'arrive plus expliquer la
complexité des décisions qui sont prises
et on n'arrive plus à surpasser les
motions qui brûle tout la démagogie
populisme pour faire entendre parce que
c'est très compliqué c'est très
technique qu'il y ait des mesures qui
font pas beaucoup de bruit mais qui font
vraiment avancer les choses et en
matière de défense de la laïcité ces
dernières années on a beaucoup avancé
sans faire de bruit vous entend sur ce
point sur cette loi séparatisme vous
savez parler merci beaucoup car une fois
installé vous restez avec nous c'est
l'heure d'accueillir nos chroniqueurs on
continue à parler de cet entre deux
tours on passe au crible avec les
scanner maintenant
[Musique]
mais avant les dons il y a les deux pas
de fatalité au grand remplacement et de
la môle vous propose le rose delmore
d'agir pour le climat l'assimilation
la république c'est moi la prendre
orange ma chronique
travailleuses et travailleurs le système
bose exclu il ya un vrai problème de
pouvoir d'achat rendre à la france sa
grandeur caritas a pas de mystère c'est
le vol
deux chroniqueurs sur ce plateau en ce
vendredi soir thierry vedel du cevipof
bonsoir vous allez nous parler ce soir
de l'importance ou non de ce débat
d'entre deux tours tous les cinq ans est
ce qu'il est déterminant sur le résultat
final mais on commence avec le carnet de
campagne de stéphane bonsoir stéphane
davet de blacko attiré par guy par quoi
aujourd'hui alors c'est votre oeil et
que je voudrais attirer deux cartes de
france ils vont apparaître par la magie
de la télévision mais voilà et on voit
les résultats du premier tour présenté
par commune c'est à dire que on voit
qu'il ya 36000 communes en france et que
dans vingt mille de ces communes marine
le pen était en tête et que emmanuel
macron lui n'arrive 2000 voilà à peu
près la moitié du nom de deux communes
dont il a obtenu plus de voir emmanuel
macron exact jours parce que les vingt
mille communes qui ont placé marine le
pen en fait ce sont souvent des petits
villages 75 % des communes au moins de
1000 habitants donc effectivement ça
fait beaucoup de petits villages mais
pas beaucoup d'électeurs ou d'habitants
tandis que évidemment avec mâcon sont
des villes plus grandes de plus grande
taille et donc plus peuplées donc au
final donc au nombre d'électeurs c'est
la fameuse opposition france
périphérique france des métropoles
exactement et ses lustres super bien sur
la carte on voit même qu'autour des
métropoles voilà il ya un blanc pour la
métropole qui ne votent pas bas le pen
et puis autour on veut tous les français
qui le paie plus open source donc de la
france périphérique c'est ce qu'ils
vivent en dehors des grandes villes et
des banlieues et ils ont besoin de leur
voiture ils souffrent pas de la
désertification des centre-villes des
déserts médicaux et un peu ceux ci qui
sont qui ont protesté pendant le
mouvement des jd jong-il l'a bien
compris tous à marine le pen et donc que
son argument aujourd'hui pour en traiter
de les attirer c'est de dire la droite
la gauche ça n'existe plus les
accusations caroline fourest comme quoi
je serais d'extrême droite mais enfin
c'est faux tout ça maintenant et
remplacée par une opposition entre deux
blocs voilà on écoute
ce rendez vous du 24 avril vous l'avez
compris mesdames et messieurs mais face
à face le bloc populaire contre le bloc
élitaire le blog de ceux attachés à la
sécurité sociale contre le bloc de ceux
attachés au pouvoir de l'argent le bloc
de ceux attachés au service public
contre le bloc de ceux qui vendent des
fleurons de notre industrie le bloc de
ceux qui considèrent le peuple comme le
seul souverain contre le bloc qui
concède le pouvoir aux seuls techniciens
en parlant du bloc populaire on pense
aussi aux électeurs de jean luc
mélenchon qui filmait bruller union
populaire et c'est le problème de la
france populaire la france d'en bas de
la france périphérique vous l'appelez
comme vous voulez c'est qu'en fait elle
reste divisée entre le vote mélenchon et
le vote marine le pen il ya 60% des
français nous disaient qu'ils soient
bien lui qui vivent la france
périphérique donc ils sont majoritaires
ils devraient être en mesure de faire
élire un candidat ou une candidate qui
défendrait vraiment leur intérêt mais
bon cette division ça les empêche
justement de décider donc ce que dit
elle maintenant marine le pen puisque
elle pourrait attirer les électeurs de
mélenchon c'est peut-être barrage mais
pas le peine sept barrages à celui que
vous détestez vous aussi emmanuel macron
si les français ont à faire barrage set
au retour d'emmanuel macron
oui
démarrage faire barrage à l'effondrement
du pouvoir d'achat des français faire
barrage au matraquage fiscal faire
barrage à la retraite à 64 ou 65 ans et
plus sauf que si on regarde les reports
par rapport à 2010 est seulement 7% des
électeurs mêlant schalke 10e pour parer
de la semaine devrait arrêter de dire le
report à 7% seulement en fait ça cette
part elle semble augmenter un peu là
j'ai regardé les derniers chiffres
parlent de 20 % donc des lecteurs de
mélenchon qui se rapporterait sur le pen
dans d'autres sondages on voit même plus
tôt jusqu'à 30 % 30 % ce qui est sûr il
ya ben voilà vos collègues qui montrait
la même appréciation en tout cas été
publiés par tf1 des chaînes de
l'autorité publique donc ce qui est sûr
c'est que 8 millions de français font à
peu près d'accord ou presque les
millions de français qui ont voté
mélenchon est donc pour les convaincre
évidemment il faut aller les chercher
avec des arguments bain de mélenchon se
dire que quand on l'entend parler marine
le pen est ce qu'elle disait hier en
avignon comme on dit c'est des phrases
qu'on a pu entendre dans la bouche de
jean luc mélenchon la vision mondialiste
d' emmanuel macron elle prône la
dérégulation et asservi l'homme aux
logiques économiques et comptables
loi du marché et à l'argent roi et on
n'est pas encore à vouloir abolir le
capitalisme mais cette dénonciation
devait l'argent est un argument ne bouge
l'argent qui corrompt mitterrand s'en
souvient alors qu'est-ce qui est le plus
convaincant quand emmanuel macron de 10
doses profit nos vies valent plus que
leurs profits ou quand elle dit au
l'argent roi de m'en parler parce que
les électeurs de mélenchon et les
abstentionnistes qui vont trancher pas
nous menace mais pardon mondialisme
c'est un mode extra mourad c'est utilisé
par serge ayoub est la pire extrême
rôtissoire c'est un mélange entre
dénoncé soi-disant la mondialisation et
le cosmopolitisme c'est ça le
mondialisme csn sous texte en tout cas
il me semble que l'argument voilà se
sont fait entendre pour tous ceux qui
ont souffert de la d1 et serait sur les
planches sentiment que l'ours halloween
c'est parce que on les a on a fait
fabriquer des objets d'une montre je
pense que même si aucun spécialiste ou
bien une différence
le sens des mots aussi alors thierry ce
soir décisif comme on dit ou pas décisif
ces grands débats que les français
attendent un vendredi soir pourquoi là
on va parler de plus en plus de ce débat
au fur et à mesure qu'on va s'approcher
en effet c'est une vieille question
qu'on se pose en sciences politiques
depuis depuis le fameux débat entre
kennedy nixon en 1960 alors les enquêtes
les travaux les études réalisées sur le
sujet globalement elle montre que ces
débats ils n'ont qu'un impact marginal
voire même négligeable la plupart du
temps nous regardons nous évaluons les
débats en fonction de nos opinions et de
nos valeurs politiques préalables et
mêmes d'ailleurs souvent nous sommes
assez sélectif nous allons retenir
telles petites phrases tels propos tels
passages en fonction de ce qu'on pense
déjà un et donc finalement les débats
ils nous servent surtout à conforter nos
opinions plus qu'elle et construire mais
alors 2017 dans tout ça parce que c'est
un débat qui est particulier est ce
qu'on fout là
auparavant avant d'aborder le débat de
2017 je voudrais dire un mot peut-être
si si si j'ai quelques secondes sur
pourquoi il ya l'impact est assez
marginal je crois qu'il ya deux raisons
principales d'abord les débats télévisés
interviennent généralement ans de
campagne un moment où les images des
candidats sont relativement structure
est bien est presque figée et les
informations qu'on peut obtenir lors
d'un débat finalement c'est une goutte
d'eau par rapport à toutes les
informations qu'on a déjà reçu au
préalable puis deuxième raison ne
l'oublions pas tout le monde ne va pas
regarder le débat
on estime à peu près qu'un gros tiers de
l'électorat peut être un petit peu plus
en fonction de l'enjeu va regarder le
débat et ceux qui le regardent quand
même ils sont plus intéressés par la
politique et on sait qu'en général ils
ont des opinions un peu plus affirmé ils
sont peut-être un peu moins vulnérables
les avis ne sont pas devant la télé
est en tout cas le 2 - ca -
puisqu'aujourd'hui on a d'autres sources
d'information et d'autres sources de
divertissement que la télévision donc on
peut passer une soirée sur internet
netflix a donné 17 est ce que c'est un
débat qui appelle justement 2010 est
la règle il ya eu quelque chose de
particulier à lui-même deux
particularités la première et c'est
quelque chose d'assez étonnant c'est que
très majoritairement les téléspectateurs
ont considéré qu'un des deux
protagonistes emmanuel macron avait été
le vainqueur qu'il avait été bien
meilleure que que l'autre et y compris
c'est ça qui est peut-être un petit peu
surprenant parmi les électeurs de marine
le pen bien une grande partie avait
considéré qu'elle n'avait pas été à la
hauteur et même un tiers d'entre eux
avaient considéré que ma kron avait
emporté le débat certains militants
frontistes
alors ça c'est les perceptions mais
quand on pense ensuite au niveau des
changements sur le vote cercle y en a eu
un petit peu plus calme que d'habitude
mais ils ont pas et est massif grosso
modo ce qu'on a observé après le débat
de 2017 ces deux grands mouvements d'une
part il ya des abstentionnistes des
électeurs qui avaient l'intention de sa
de s'abstenir qui se sont mobilisés en
faveur d' emmanuel macron et inversement
il ya des électeurs qui initialement
avait l'intention de voter pour marine
le pen qui se sont eux qui se sont
détournés d'elle et qui sont réfugiés
dans l'abstention et tout ça mais ceci
dit c'est ça représente 3% et donc
finalement si je peux me permettre un
mot de conclusion je dirais qu'un débat
télévisé c'est un peu comme il faut
faire une grande différence entre la
perception qu'on peut avoir et la
perception que les médias en haut rang
et les effets effectifs l'impact
effectif c'est un peu comme un match de
rugby si vous voulez parfois l'équipe à
laquelle on est attaché elle fait pas le
meilleur jeu probable goddyn 3% de de
faire bouger un score de 3 ports et là
quand on est à 55 49 ça peut être
important mais seulement brice
téléspectateurs
c'est pas un match comme un autre entre
lui et elle s'est pas qu'entre deux
projets différents au sein de l'arc
républicain c'est entre deux visions du
monde de la france qui peuvent nous
faire basculer dans une abîme donc je
pense que c'est plus important entre
elle et lui que jamais un débat merci à
vous on va s'arrêter là merci pour vos
chroniques merci caroline forest c'est
la fin de cette émission merci nous
avons regardé c'est le week end profitez
bien soirée documentaire quais
commencent ce soir tout
[Musique]